what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have some new spider-man no way
home clips to break down but
this specific clip connects doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
one division to spider-man no way home
and we could be possibly seeing a little
bit of a tease of what the post-credits
scene for no way home at least one of
them could be we know that marvel
studios loves to connect everything
after all it is the mcu so today we'll
look at some footage that hints that one
division and loki could be connected to
spider-man now at home which of course
is going to lead into doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness in which the
scarlet witch is going to be a main
character in and right now it's looking
like the ending of one division could be
directly connected to the ending of
spider-man no way home and of course we
know marvel there aren't really that
many coincidences in marvel everything's
usually connected so i'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video and of course if you did not catch
my video yesterday i am doing a massive
giveaway that's going to be running
until the end of december all you got to
do is subscribe to my channel and the
other channels and social media accounts
listed in the description and pin
comment down below so like i mentioned
the ending of doctor strange kind of
looks like the ending from one division
let's check both of these out so we can
compare the two now pay close attention
to the background of this scene
[Music]
rooms
in a given space
only the witch who cast them
can use her magic
so as we can see here and as agatha
harkness says wanda cast runes and as we
were taught in one division in a given
space only the witch or in doctor
strange's case the wizard who casts the
runes can use his magic or her magic now
take a look at this scene from
spider-man no way home where we see
doctor strange doing something pretty
familiar
all right parker
you ready
world if you're watching
wish me luck
exclusively in cinemas coming soon
if we freeze frame this we can actually
see that doctor strange has indeed cast
some runes as well at least it really
really looks like it now keep in mind
this scene right here is a part of the
scene that we saw in the official
trailer where dr strange says at the
very end they're starting to come
through and i can't stop them now as far
as what's coming through we don't really
know yet of course there are a lot of
theories going from other villains are
actually going to be coming in other
variants of maybe doc ock electro etc or
the theory that i propose myself that
other worlds are actually breaking
through other different universes in the
premise of secret wars battle world all
of the universes kind of collide into
each other and of course we know that
when marvel decides to adapt comics into
the mcu they don't do it exactly as they
were they kind of just take motivation
and influence from them and if marvel
studios's next huge avengers in-game
level event is going to be secret wars
years down the road they'll start
building into it much like they did with
the very first phases of the mcu and
perhaps this is a little glimpse of
these universes colliding because if you
think about it multiverse of madness is
about the multiverse being thrown into
madness and how does that happen well
universes colliding and not staying in
their own course and being their own
universes that could do the trick and
this is where loki and one division get
tied into spider-man no way home at the
end of one division ago of the harkness
says you have no idea what you've done
and what happened was wanda truly became
the scarlet witch in which we learned
from agatha harkness they are not really
supposed to exist and one division
teased nexus throughout the series so
this could have very well caused a nexus
event otherwise why did they tease us
with nexus now nexus beans in marvel
comics have the ability to alter the
universal flow of time and this is where
loki comes in we learned from loki that
if anything really major happens that's
not supposed to happen that creates an
alternate timeline and now that sophie
killed he who remains based off of what
he who remains said there's really not
going to be anybody to kind of stop
these alternate timelines from growing
and the true kang is going to be coming
we know that because of ant-man and the
wasp quantomania and not to mention when
sophie and loki got to he who remains he
said that he had never been past that
part and that means that could have been
a nexus event as well so what seems to
be happening is realities are kind of
fusing together now this combined with
dr strange's spell going wrong affecting
the multiverse affecting reality as he
says in the trailers well this could
cause a tear in all of reality causing
the universes to come together because
if you take a careful look at the
background of a few of these scenes from
spider-man knowing home where dr strange
is talking about them coming through we
can kind of see the universe is tearing
reality is tearing and since he says
they're starting to come through it is
very possible that he is referring to
other universes so what exactly is he
doing now casting runes so keep in mind
there are different runes we can assume
and we can assume that doctor strange's
magic is different than wandas his is
learned and wanda's is natural yes i
know she got her powers from an infinity
stone but agatha hartness did explain
that she had the power inside of her
since she was a kid so that's what i'm
talking about so doctor strange's runes
could be very different they may not
just be so he can be the only one to use
magic they could be that but i think
they're a bit more i think he's probably
casting something to protect his reality
to try to shut the gate between our
universe and other universes that could
be breaking in because let's keep in
mind we actually don't know when all of
this takes place in the mcu a lot of
people have synced up the events of loki
with he who remains with the events of
one division's finale and that makes
sense two major things happening at the
same time that affect reality and based
off what we know and concluded one
division takes place not too long after
the events of avengers end game this
means that it takes place months before
spider-man no way home and if loki
happened at the same time that's two
major events that are affecting reality
so reality is already pretty fragile so
now i think that doctor strange's spell
are kind of the tip of the iceberg now
as far as breaking or cracking our
reality and i think these runes that
he's casting here could be trying to
offset what happened in one vision and
save their universe from letting other
universes in now this does look very
similar to what wanda was doing and like
i mentioned in the beginning she is
going to be one of the main characters
of multiverse of madness so we could
probably assume since spider-man goes
right into multiverse of madness that
there'll be a teaser in a post-credits
scene for multiverse madness and since
thanks feel pretty one division here it
could be a tease of the scarlet witch
after all the last time we saw wanda she
was reading from the darkhold learning
more magic dark magic and it seemed like
she found her kids in a different
reality and based off of what we know
from the trailers of no way home doctor
strange says they tampered with reality
so everything is connected here and it's
heavily rumored that wanda's twins will
show up in multiverse of madness so i'm
predicting that a tease is coming for
that film and i would not be surprised
one bit if the scarlet witch shows up
now of course keep in mind this is a
sony and marvel studios film so i'm
assuming one of them is going to be sony
spider-man universe related and then
another one marvel studios universe
related but leave your best thoughts
down below all your predictions all your
theories let me know what you think
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can enter the giveaway
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you